l'essence à 1 franc 60 2 on croit rêver
et pourtant c'était le 11 janvier 1974
il y a seulement six ans à l'époque
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence
provoqué l'indignation j'avais une
voiture mais est ce que vous envisagez
vous en servir - oui parce que ça me
revient trop cher donc vous allez
marcher un peu plus ce exact et cette
même pour les santé c'est bien je pense
que la sélection qui aura à faire cet
arrêté de rouler pendant quinze jours
pour moi c'est un coup dur direct mais
je suis coincé je suis obligé de me
servir d'un voiture mais je pense que
les week-ends si jamais déplacé je me
servirai ce ne fut qu'une parole en
l'air six mois plus tard les français
sentent assez aux portes des vacances il
ne renonçait pas à l'indépendance que
procure la voiture il allait même
jusqu'à lui pardonner ses défaillances
mais en 74 déjà on enregistrait
également un autre type de réaction j'ai
également une voiture tout petit
d'ailleurs inquiet de 500 qui ne
consomment pas beaucoup d'essence
l'augmentation des prix de l'essence je
m'en fous cette voiture laissée récente
éventuellement par la suite sujet
remplaçant de prendre une voiture ou
multi sur ce point de la réduction de
cylindrée de nombreux automobilistes
sont passés à l'action
le nombre d'immatriculations ne cesse de
croître mais la faible consommation
d'essence est devenu un argument de
vente
en 1981 voici comment les lyonnais
réagissaient ce matin face à cette
nouvelle augmentation
c'est bien ça nous porte à gros budget
c'est l'ouvrir dans tous ses duels à
digérer mais
obligé de supporter les conséquences qui
se veut faire rentrer j'avais leur âge
j'ai pris 25
da et deux sorties maintenant
on les diminue j'ai l'impression que les
français réagissent un petit peu moins
et qu'ils baissent les bras quand ces
augmentations successives
oui c'est mon avis aussi je pense qu'il
faudrait faire un effort conduit les
constructeurs automobiles
l'effort a déjà été fait chez plusieurs
constructeurs français au niveau de la
consommation d'autre part des modèles
diesel sont maintenant installés sur des
voitures de tourisme
de plus la technique du turbocompresseur
après avoir fait ses preuves sur les
poids lourds est déjà utilisée sur la
604 elle le sera en avril sur la r5
[Musique]